way worse now but could you might have
worked sit yeah yeah okay yeah I'm gonna
go back to Utah I think it takes a
second to update itself all right so far
okay so if the other thing over there so
I'm gonna play it and see what that
looks like boom boom let's see if
anyone's joined us pending the second
for it to load
okay well then let's not say anything
embarrassing just embarrassing enough
watching if you're watching this is
Wendy Wendy Harry she's taking out all
my extensions and putting a new one with
my sentence are gross and this is the
only time than that to get it done
honestly grace has been so busy that
we're having a long time you guys know
how the first you guys know how this
works the first like ten minutes we just
been not knowing what the [ __ ] we're
doing no and you guys think it's a bit
we've developed it it's not that's just
our brains don't operate well it's a bit
annoying how bad we are at this yeah I'm
sure the Google Plus changes [ __ ]
I feel like yeah and I don't I'm like
consecutively livestream or continue
like I don't do it enough
right remember the steps every time like
Hannah's got a process I should know it
but I don't like how short the hair is
when the extensions are crazy and I
wouldn't ask money to come do my hair is
like by the way we might also be
live-streaming know if Wendy's sister is
watching hi Wendy's sister Irene is just
so cute okay let's see okay it's got
people watching there they're slowly
joining although they're hey guys
greetings
oh hey Wendy or you might know her from
doing all of Grace's hair in her book
yes now you guys all have and see how
great it looks
yeah and she did the Hollywood photos
for all of us that Robin rumor oh yeah
oh yeah all the do you see the once
beautiful rolls see that just makes me I
was like that sounds like some kind of
cinnamon bun that Guy Fieri would get on
diners drive-ins and dives
it's true no we look very Alaska and you
look Portland I love the last mom I do
seriously Rock a lot of the Portland
flow think we got on a daily basis I the
flannel that I got there really comes in
handy okay okay okay I don't know where
the refresh button is on this
I don't understand how this works
they're loading cool okay so oh yeah
I'll be able to get some stuff oh yeah
how do you run this should we get the
breakdown of what's gonna happen and how
long we're gonna be here for everyone
knows right up front right up tribe
we're gonna be here for one hour yes
we'll be here till 6:00 p.m. doing an
impression we so we just went on a
filter tour yeah and which was so much
fun such a blast I'm sure so many of you
guys were there yeah but the only bummer
was that we were doing a show on
Halloween so I didn't get to dress up
beans I know her first Halloween that
cat has to be saved it's like witnessing
a baby's christening did you have ideas
before we knew we were doing a show of
what you might have made her into I mean
you've dressed her up so many times I
think if I was gonna dress her up it
would definitely be some sort of combo
okay you know would be fun cute I mean
this might be too classic
I definitely do something weirder but
just [ __ ] straight-up wicked witch and
she's a flying monkey
oh that's really great I was also
thinking because that's incredible
save it however I think I would have to
be Joey Chestnut like when I was bad at
eating hot dogs she's great any boiled
eggs so maybe we good good thank you for
coming up support I am AI think in this
boy I think that script that you had in
your brain about it yeah no spoilers I'm
still trying to make a
competitive-eating movie all right
people are here yes we can see the
YouTube comments
Becca 11 dance we can see it and I'm
also going
be looking through on Twitter if you
guys hashtag hey USA I can find it
pretty easily Oh first right off back
Greg Varley says hey girls I'm not kid
that bought you drinks at pink taco in
LA remembers me and I'm just not we
hardly ever ever take drinks from people
ever ever ever but you were so nice so
still doesn't convince us to trust
strangers never ever ever take a drink
even if they're as adorable as mr.
barley there yes don't take drinks for
dangerous seemingly harmless okay so we
know we're doing this till 6:00 yes
sweet wish we I mean this is killing me
by the way I don't want to now person
that I don't know we are forced to have
a conversation for hours because their
extensions take a lot of time why do you
think my hair is so long wait talking
not you any of course you're different
but like before just like but like
randos that like half an hour of small
talk I guess one time went in New York
to on the very much don't like the cusp
of the Upper East Side area ish and I
just didn't talk and they were okay with
that they're like you know whatever like
the girl instantly kind of understood
however they were different people doing
[ __ ] like like transition it was so
expensive I hate it you know what you
could do though
yeah which maybe I'll try Wendy's not
available at times is just go in and be
like
Oh idea Celine Dion that [ __ ] hey all
right so let's take a couple questions I
think we are gonna watch an episode yeah
so to start tweeting at us and let us
know which is your favorite episode that
you'd love for all of us to collectively
watch mm-hmm and what's our what's our
hashtag for this one I think it was like
hey yo say live okay he will say live
hey what's a live show tweet us your
questions what episode you want us to
watch etc etc give us all the goods give
us all the goods oh also speaking of
tour stuff you and I have another tour
coming up wait if you guys have a song
please do it yeah hold on let me see
this one quick thing and then we'll talk
about that for sure yeah grace tell
everyone that the linked from the
subscription box doesn't work and you
have to go to your channel what I don't
even know what that means a link from
the subscription box doesn't work oh you
mean if you go to my page it doesn't
load on the main page let's see let's
see try out we will so so you go there
and then you go there yeah where's your
basis isn't one else people seem to be
watching I think yeah I hope so I
tweeted out just my channel name so cool
all right yeah oh so before we dive into
all the hey USA craziness yeah so grace
and I are going on tour we get weird
yeah and we're going to the South East
area for the most part yeah and we're
going like we went to New Orleans for
Maine USA or going back to do this might
get weird I know should we like have
Bloody Mary come do something on stage
or like one of the characters we met
there do something I don't know
but make sure you guys go get your
tickets if you live in Nashville
Charlotte North Carolina honestly guys
laia review Ben could you please make me
like look good it in from people I know
I need you I sure go to sellout she's
yelling at us to go to North Carolina
since we first started touring and now
we finally are going and so no
[ __ ] need to buy your tickets
yeah I'm stressed okay so we are doing
Texas saying there's two videos on the
channel but the one you tweet it works
there's two videos on the two videos on
your channel is that because the first
let me say I love that word 15 minutes
in we're still we're idiots that I still
figuring it out videos it doesn't show
them oh god it which I don't know how to
do it all
yeah sure so if you guys are a pro this
is all your friends and enemies to come
watch us please just use my channel page
oh but so we're doing Nashville and
Charlotte's not this weekend but the
next never doing Atlanta and then we are
doing he's in what you say
see this is what stuff is that it's like
time Iligan guys it but that's 10th a is
a Tempe Arizona or Tempe I'm gonna get
all [ __ ] for but you have German fans
too I know we do seriously an apartment
oh yeah we would love to come too I mean
we'd love to go on there and tour and
we'd also love to do more hey USA stuff
that maybe we do more in the u.s. maybe
we do more other places we just like
traveling
I think we're getting really
any better at it we're so getting better
at it yeah anything better and Eddie's
up too but I remember when I first
started like traveling more frequently I
would always forget something and that
still happens I always forget something
but I'm far less stressed about it when
I realize it's happen that because I
realize that there are ways to
problem-solve let their stores yes their
stores and hotel have like every
toiletry you needs they don't advertise
that you know when we were on the snow
filter tour I asked for cheese brush at
every single city since I didn't bring
like I left it and every goes down and I
got a new one is every single I got it
y'all just cuz they don't put it in the
room doesn't mean they don't have it
right everything you need I mean the
reason is no they definitely give you
like an old cheering blade it's kind of
gross and and don't take it if it has a
pube on it um oh let me go back to this
video so I can see got any questions or
anything on on the Twitter Sunday people
which city did you poop in the most
question I'm trying to think what we ate
the funkiest does that
wait which do we pooping I'm going to
the Atlantis show I really say this
you're Atlanta I think and then is one
of the cities that I wish I love you
asking like what city dippy not go to
that we would have wanted to go to no
huh and I feel like Atlanta is one of
those cities I totally do - I used to go
to Atlanta when I was little because yep
is growing up when my dad was doing um
when he was working on a show it films
like half an hour outside of Atlanta so
we would still go to Atlanta Braves
games and things like that and then I
went to basketball camp there all camp
like Georgia Tech I played sports until
high school I understand my step team
when I was in elementary school and like
still just would not come to terms with
like I didn't have that talent I really
really wanted to be sporty I just was
not so I played like softball on a
second base and then I was so bad I'm
also so extremely bad at basketball and
everyone assumes because I'm yeah well
luckily I was still short when I was
little so then they had me be a guard oh
she's right I love Trotter I'd have to
go to someone literally I think when we
got to Minneapolis there's like come to
a show in New York it was like mother
[ __ ] we were just there the past two
nights but we'd love to go back to the
UK we're obsessed with it
yeah what song most reminds you of the
Heisei experience this summer oh that's
a really good question yeah I don't
think we listen to a lot of music
we did we were when we weren't doing
stuff if we were ever in like the
production ban going from one point to
another
we didn't play music ever because we
just needed to yeah yeah memories
resuming me and also are usually a PA
that was driving the car
mm-hmm I think for the most part the PA
feels comfortable asking like they don't
want to listen
no actually come to think of it we
really never listen to music to the
point where that's probably why I made
up so many songs oh yeah totally because
we never listened to music we didn't
have musical and we were always pumping
music in our trailer right but I will
say that Thank You music reminded me of
two-stepping
in Austin which we just stopped yes lose
this [ __ ] out oh we found out that Terry
our two second structure terrible Terry
terrifying Terry who was wonderful we
love tiny Miley Cyrus she's on she did
an episode of manzo'd with children on
Bravo like does she teach them how to
two-step I sincerely hope so also
I want to see the hair off between her
and Caroline net so because of Mary
Caroline old haircut
hey why I was the first the first of the
two I watched it but wait Caroline's on
there
what tickets let me tell you something
dad my family's legacy seems like
actually I've known you talk to each
other
namaste [ __ ] but yeah we didn't have
a song listen to me to be look the thing
move to step two is called hell cat just
slid across the floor like she was Tom
Cruise in risky business yes exactly
because it was a guy that didn't work
there yeah it's his mom yeah we got
permission to use the show so much fun
oh so innocent they're gonna be moving
to Iceland and want to host us on a
blind adventure that's very sweet
and also Hawaii was a place that we like
big it goes we really wanted to go
actually what happened was they we
didn't have the last City plans here we
were gonna go yet and you know at this
point we've been traveling all [ __ ]
summer yeah like crazy this on top of
like finishing books and doing the
million things and a shot a pilot and so
much stuff that by the time we chose the
last one our producers got blessum they
were like we want to treat you guys
we're gonna go Hawaii and they're like
no we were like can we stay in LA Oh
before we started the show we went and
looked at all the like these are places
were going and they put white just to
[ __ ] with the last one and of course
that's the first card we
let's go to why Amir Allah can we just
yeah and two and a half Sunnah it was
like two and half months cuz we actually
we shot like forty days really that's a
lot of bang on camera a ton of being a
wreck and a ton of just like packing up
and moving I'm moving this
are you guys getting like the full
sliding doors looks so good what do you
guys think
tell me in the comments I can't tell
when you're getting your hair cut
yeah but not sure because the look I
look like a chipmunk right no no I just
need to take it up a couple of inches
okay no caller ID keeps calling me
should I answer the phone and skilled
workforce it's like something serious
and personal it won't be okay
oh hi yes you owe us money we get to see
you main town puking before salmon
fishing loops maybe wait Oh get me no
because it was here's why it could have
been later in the series you would have
been on camera a hundred percent yeah
our very first weekend and our producer
taking portraying it we're also very
sweet and respectful didn't you know
like what was appropriate to film us
Jewish memory is like totally having a
terrible body experience and we're in a
production van and it's weaving through
the mountain terrain salmon fishing so
it's like all of these things added
together it made me finally be late wait
to pull over you could pull over and we
pulled over and she's on the front seat
and it was like it was like perfect
movie moment that your head was just on
the frame of me they want to see you see
me lead over and then Chad or producer
gets out the baby was driving he found
like I clean we have oh but in literally
he goes to hand it to you and he sees
you guys vomited and it just literally
looks exactly how it looked on the plate
so we like even though you were fine but
we like idioms went to a Thai place in
the middle of a fishing village osku
it's like what do we do like eat like
local eat potatoes that's what they eat
so we go to like the one exotic
restaurant and like this tiny ice town
and then that pad thai I mean it came up
about a - I don't know
I was so low well anyone knows mayor's
work with me it goes very well what's my
number one most important sit down I go
to the bathroom I come back already has
a Bloody Mary and then we're looking at
the menu of a big gamble order and then
memory starts talking about she can't
wait to get back to her couch and order
Thai food from oh yeah yeah I was like
what should I order for dinner literally
my life is planning what my next meal is
so the point where you know I don't
think you've seen it but you know maybe
some of y'all got it in a beautiful mind
when like you realize that Russell
spoiler that Russell Crowe isn't a
genius he's actually like crazy
that's my mind just being like I'm gonna
kill it from here from here like just
trying to arrange how my next meal can
be perfect that was kind of like it was
kind of like either dude Key West or
p-town because they're both I mean
they're totally different like terrain
wise but they're both like flamboyant I
love us I want to be wise for two spring
breaks one of them you'll read in my
book about like where would we want to
retire and we were like retire forever I
mean not according to Michael Jordan I
don't know I don't know I don't think I
know yet where I'm gonna retire but I do
know based on this summer where I'd like
to go
in the summer yeah I feel like really
wacky to spirituality as I got a tweet
from Billy Billy film who was our main
producer that's it why did you guys go
away I mean literally can't do anything
else - this is this is just what its
gonna be sorry
Oh best purchase during hey USA I think
your favorite piece of clothing was that
I loved we didn't purchase these
production I purchased them for us the
ones that we've warned you were anything
last night
which one the ones you took a photo
diamond last night
oh no these forget those were covered in
loose right the flannel one we wore and
Heartland all the onesies we got we got
one in Alaska we got the red one when we
went lobstering in p-town yeah we got
the flannel one in Portland when we're
on segways because by the way over last
night it's really convenient that it's
really convenient yeah I think that's
why they are what they are that onesie
constantly all those onesies they're
good stuff they're good stuff should we
watch it episode yeah I mean there's so
few tweeting so many
one what's your favorite episode great
my favorite and then we'll give you guys
a few minutes so that you can like open
another window and pull up the scene and
then watch it with us
Oh buddy I need your passcode well we're
not telling anyone okay I'll go through
that
yeah I'm just to refresh for now so New
Orleans Austin Anchorage Louisville
Sedona P Town Portland LA I would say I
think I want to watch TV at Portland OR
Ala yeah I didn't see to be honest I
didn't watch a ton of the LA one only
what we were doing hello hello no sorry
you had the wrong number
no worries have a good day literally
this is what just happened
I could watch la questions and then [ __ ]
it I'll play the camping scene that was
the last night we ever shot which you'll
see but like literally like what do we
do now we've set up the tent
and would we divulge in two ways to make
the time pass camping I think that's the
hardest I laughed watching the show you
little pinata yeah we have been coming
up with so much stuff constantly like on
the spot I mean things
we got nothing okay here's question
these are sent to us from the scene via
act hello
h XR co how much did it hurt when named
Rafael fall off the Segway trans I hurt
pretty bad
I can't hurt you anymore the ego was
bruised the worst but it hurt really bad
but luckily I mean it did really hurt my
ankle
it was [ __ ] yeah I did her but luckily
enough I landed on my ass the thing that
hurt the most
oh there's a fly on your computer which
makes us like there's a black what do
you want this welcome to the way no one
filmed her when we were in Alaska on the
first one everyone film terms yeah
exactly like they didn't feel me puking
but they were just like laughing at me
from Segway didn't flinch she was just
like boom take it but the thing that
hurt the most cuz I mean I had some
run-ins with that thing that hurt the
most the entire time were those [ __ ]
racer skaters with just need to face my
fear it was great but so I was covered
in bruises like jaundice donations like
it was just like yellow and purple
everywhere while we do this guy open up
a dip Bravo chahe USA not the scene
calm and pull it up the LA episode and
we will all watch it together
oh I stole that I know what it is I'm
gonna screw up your work of French who
is one person that you've met during the
trip who you would like to make a video
for your channel with oh well first we
met during the trip that we'd like to
make a video and it would be yeah okay
what's his face for beat down drag queen
was both developed a crush on Ryan Ryan
Landry he was the best
he was fantastic also just miss
Richfield I feel like and you look so
amazing together true and homeboy at
Buffalo Trace bourbon down i watch that
I'm like how are your ribs thing and
here's the thing we showed up fully
dressed like that head to toe he didn't
say one inch we were just like okay and
intro hey guys were here bro what's up
we're gonna come over and then he's like
come on girls let's go and then boys are
Alicia's on and we had such a time
crunch getting the full tour of the
distillery then he was just like our
hero he was phenomenal he was phenomenal
yes okay so do you guys have your thing
pulled up right you ready
great I'm gonna load let me make sure
it's loaded make sure
okay hey you say album granted it could
be twenty songs and it still only be two
minutes long because they don't really
like have verses but okay you ready okay
I'll set it up
oh my god are you guys ready are you
guys ready
Barack's just together this is gonna be
some female Mystery Science Theater
science it's gonna be how I get its work
okay and this is awesome yeah I can just
hold it oh so I'll bring it close so you
guys can hear always start it yeah all
right we are ready
hurry freshet okay ready undivided
attention
sorry I'm just multitasking yay okay I'm
set oh cool ready it's loaded I'm
hitting play
you got some kappa this opening is so
cute was the sweetest guy and I was just
okay yeah that's when I thought that
tank top was a good idea I don't know I
don't worry I should not wear sleeveless
yes this is all so they just dropped us
off in the middle of Hollywood to pick
up the shot and everyone's cuddling
Islands yeah it was a wheel that
literally just moved so much before it
actually moved the car you're gonna go I
was too scared tries clenching my ball
the entire time
well I was too but just reverse kegel
son what I would like to know is why the
producers thought putting you and a
hamster shirt was a good idea with me
I know memories very much afraid of
rodents many times this is like 6 a.m. I
do yeah it's so early
and this guys we're making pediatric
jokes about not wanting to do it he's
like Mike Brown you know we're tired
when I drink a Red Bull yeah we look
good though
ten hours to get these scuba suits on so
wet suit on and 20 X o'clock pause and
pause guys first of all this is what the
screen looks like that we're paused on
right now we go to Malibu to go surfing
and we get our wet suits and we're like
cool great we're seeing them where does
the changing room and then they point to
[ __ ] port-a-john
oh we're not okay we're not princesses
no like you have to take your shoes off
to put on a wetsuit no I'm [ __ ]
porta-johns the one that wasn't
we went we went to Arizona we went dune
buggying and then we like stopped some
could go see those ancient ruin yeah and
we stopped and we went to the bathroom
that was there
I'm not kidding guys it was just a hole
so the hole went doors around this lever
like oh it's a real bathroom
I'm in the door and it's like a hand
okay so there was like really a well of
[ __ ] underneath it that's in the desert
so essentially it's a within a 20-foot
radius you forgot Mel it was its spread
but so when we were going surfing we had
to put on the wet suits grace goes in
and she does it and she comes out to
think oh my god
no and I go in there and I just start
and you can't like you don't want your
foot to touch the ground get the [ __ ]
portage on they don't let you change
there they're not gonna let you walk did
know we're like we need your bathroom
yeah we had our towel like I cleaned the
floor with the towel oven through the
way yeah okay I'm gonna hit play again
you guys ready here's what it looks like
we are there's 13 minutes and 53 seconds
left on this one okay ready
you were going to kicking at surfing
though it was really fun
activities that we pretend to be hated
so much no we're doing it but mind you
we are about 50 feet inland of all other
surfers that are in the water yeah
everywhere the children oh yeah like the
really small children and I'm going to
use goodbye you gotta flick two or three
times
god bless our surfing instructor because
I just kept floating away she's got a
paddle to me to me and I'm like yeah
right after this we went to this
vineyard literally had me as anything we
are so exhausted and then you start
pumping us of wine when we got there
when we got there immediately we had to
do an interview yeah and the interview
girl she was so often him with Elise I
remember that and she was just like yeah
wine so we started drinking and then
when we got on this convertible it was
like I'm wasted
yeah Wes was a character it was his call
to have the animals make it into a zoo
vineyards very smart ooh glass yeah I
mean like what am I wearing at this
point I have no idea this is just
changing into our Beck their closer yeah
we couldn't possibly wear club I'll wear
psychedelic captures you know we're
about to see right now
yeah this Mike I think this was the
hardest you last the entire summer I
left the entire trip I was so surprised
I could not breathe there's what
good great when children rolled up with
her rockin teeth I Gracie was like no
sound I couldn't breathe I couldn't
breathe if you got a Malibu
evany know this [ __ ] exists no
creativity there's so many lines also
when we got into that frame you take
that picture I remember our producers
being like oh no she's getting up there
oh god she looks so much bigger I'm like
oh it was beg first Monday all we do is
beg for a spa day the whole summer and
then beans got the [ __ ] Sunday so
we'll make you guys wear like sweatpants
and just fashion show
oh yeah the Troy we did with everybody
we got some look oh we did that oh and I
got her of course oh my god okay so when
we were up there with the captain it was
so funny because because they spotted a
blue whale off the boat and so we were
like oh my god
blue whale it's amazing so they let's go
up to the captain's deck to see it and
our producer and told them they're like
it's a very family-friendly show like
it'll be fine and I just rektd my thing
might have been the scariest thing we
did was these fish we're destroying us
they were awful I hated them we thought
this was the better choice to do this
instead of scuba diving no they bit me
Nicole about that yeah they Randy right
look at me I'm just holding my crotch
holding my crotch like I'm about to get
kicked in the nuts by a top how many was
so fine okay yeah it's cool we're gonna
end up a deal we're doing it look guys
we're doing that thing you want us to do
we're in there oh look underwater we're
going to get eaten alive then it's real
scary I just listen we just screamed
through the snorkel hole at each other
the whole time the whole time oh you
didn't see it that it literally
like 20 minutes to get out into the
water because we couldn't get me recipes
and like it's melted to us wasn't this
clip that's all you're not seeing any of
the fish you're just see me with all the
time you're surrounded we never looked
better
camping Gavin with our friends of the
hair to lie
oh yeah the weirdest tiny grocery store
yeah and then someone reported us what
are we doing by the way what you didn't
see is the guy who runs the campground
they're literally the most is the
grumpiest it's grumpy cat as a human
yeah
Oh God give me warm champagne I'm gonna
reverb you took charge
and dear we're just like walking around
the campground this may be having her
trapped moment right now very calm they
was so good oh my god it was the best
thing I've ever eaten it was so good
Oh guys you should make them camping is
not just for people might be my favorite
lines in the show
that smells me and everyone usually
really lose it I was so out of it
ah that was so funny I'm just like we
lost it what literally you can just see
me I'm looking off camera at the
producers and cameramen is this what you
want
just what you down to our brain no I'm
like yeah listen [ __ ] everything was
funny at that point exactly
and our fritos did go missing yeah a
whole bag of Fritos or master boat okay
we got to drunk that night we haven't
ate anything that day and has a
bartender because they'd use quite a
shot just like you're good you guys with
oh my god it was a week ago I go into
our house
is she on manzo'd with children did you
guys find out yeah and I'm back in the
back of the boat packing up my stuff
Susan like I want to shrink down into a
pocket size she's a buddy who performs
in LA last week ah no filter you know
I'm drunk yeah it was much more of it
also by the way one of the favorite
things that we did is or that we've seen
is when people do the fan out or they
recreate pictures of us yes we've seen
so many you start doing this and it's us
it's awesome so we want you guys to do
more of them and you sash like hey Jose
and they'll find them because I think
hey USA is cooking up like maybe a
little like video montage project thing
yeah so please if you feel likely
creating yeah they're so good and we met
a couple of girls that have been
retreating then while we were on tour
easily and it's they're just hilarious I
also I forget all the photos that would
kick in if so many the specifics of what
we're wearing and holding and doing and
they yeah and then damnit so come by me
if you want you free if you
just recreate this right now you gotta
get yourself a windy but no take me I
need her shaken grab your also last
minute plug I just said that I'd say hey
to my brother in Australia what's up
Dave I forgot to say it earlier oh hey
hey Australia I know oh my god I wish
I've never even been there
I mean I've pretty much done all you can
do in Australia but it's cool enough
that I'd go back yeah
but then they're gonna find I don't know
[ __ ] bunch of yeah so uh we hope you
guys have fun watching this live stream
again make some more recreation stuff or
any fan art in general we [ __ ] love
people who are over at astronauts wanted
they see everything see everything
actually follow them on tumblr because
they may blog a lot of your fan art
creations yeah always use hashtags and
don't forget maybe they're going on our
tour let's make it your garlic company
shows and two weeks like in a weakening
yeah so make sure we'll have links for
tickets everywhere
yeah if you follow us on any social
media you'll be able to find them but
you can also look up just make it your
jaw and see exactly where the ticket
links and we will go on tour and travel
some more and this guy's say USA season
2 we need to come to Nashville or to you
know wherever we're going
we travel a lot and alright